creig Monday who was the CTO of this
organization took me out for dinner I
was again a young researcher and I
didn't know what it was about and he
started talking to me about this cable
DSL duopoly so he started to explain to
me how in rural America people had no
access in the Internet and the duopoly
concept was about the fact that
everybody was relying on these cable and
telcos to provide them connectivity and
they would provide connectivity where
their business model made sense so as he
was explaining this to me he started to
say well Richard we must be able to do
something in vilest to prevent that and
then he said so are you gonna do this
and this exactly how are you gonna do
this and so here's a CTO of my career
search you know that thing asking me so
that got me going on this stuff you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using
[Music]
if your idea of a great job includes
pursuing untethered research shepherding
brilliant researchers and helping shape
the long-term strategy of one of the
largest tech companies in the world oh
and also publishing prolifically
authoring patents winning awards and
speaking around the world you're in good
company that's what dr. Victor Bal
distinguished scientist and director of
mobility and networking at Microsoft
Research does for a living
and he loves it today in our first live
podcast recorded at MSR s 2018 faculty
summit dr. ball shares some fascinating
stories from his long and illustrious
career gives us an insight look at
what's new in networking and explains
why in an industry where it pays to be
the smartest person in the room it's
important to be a world-class listener
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah this is our first live podcast and
I'm honored to have you be the guest
Victor you're a distinguished scientist
and the director of mobility and
networking at MSR and you say you have
one of the best jobs in the industry how
would you describe what you do what
inspires you what gets you up in the
morning well first thank you for having
me here yeah I do have the best job you
know what I think if I reflect on what I
have you know I'm around some of the
smartest people in the world they are on
the top of their game talk to them ups
my game and every day is an exploding
experience for me I also feel that this
organization is set up amazingly well
providing complete flexibility to the
kind of things we want to pursue so we
can really go after our own passion I
also feel that our CEO has empathy and
I've shown that then that allows us to
not only just go after a tech problems
but also things that affect the societal
benefits and hey the pay is not bad
either so you know you take all that
account it's one of the best jobs I
could have had how would you describe or
define the big goal of mobility and
networking researchers at MSR what big
issues are you looking at the big
questions you're trying to solve I think
we are trying to build the most reliable
the most accessible the most secure
fastest network on the planet and so if
you think about it from that perspective
there are many many problems that you
need to solve including things like
broadband access to the billions of
people who don't have it when I talk
about accessibility that's what I'm
talking about when I talk about
reliability I'm talking about a network
that never goes down and then similarly
there are other problems same thing with
security you don't want your packets or
your data to be compromised in any way
so yeah we work on some of these things
and the scale is so large it's just
yes let's talk a little bit about
philosophies of research I kind of asked
myself you know do you ask different
kinds of questions as a researcher in
technology or do you just ask the same
questions with different deadlines where
do you fall on that question and where
do you think MSR falls on that yeah
that's a good question I think and you
bring up an interesting point about
timelines and I think that's kind of the
key tier that I believe in Microsoft
Research and we have time on our side
where as engineers and folks who work in
the product they have to deliver pretty
quickly now with time on our side that
luxury allows us to now try things that
may not get there very quickly and it'll
also allows us to take a lot of risks
and so in research I believe we deal
with ambiguity very well you know you
give us a whole set of data you give us
a generic problem and we have trained
ourselves to try to identify with great
crispness what the hard problem there is
right and then we go after that so yes
there is a difference between how you
know engineers very smart engineers will
deal with the problem in the product
space and researchers will deal with in
in dmsr space that's an interesting
comparison with the engineer and the
researcher in the sense that if you're
an engineer you have that deadline and
sometimes that can be a benefit right I
have to solve this quickly to deliver on
a deadline so it's not like we don't
give us less deadline to so we impose
these deadlines on us to sort of put a
stake in the ground in some sense of
saying you know we're on top of this
stuff so yeah deadlines do help now
there are different kinds if you have
very short deadlines and you might
compromise just to here and there to get
to that deadline and I would say that
from a researcher perspective
yeah deadlines can help incentivize you
but also they don't allow you to take
the kinds of risks that may come up with
a serendipitous discovery yeah yeah I
mean you know to be very fair and honest
about it there is a culture of trying to
produce a lot of papers right so they
put these self-imposed deadlines and
try to publish that's their sort of the
their product as I say in reality we
should be able to take time I don't
think research can be done without
leisure to be honest you really need
time to sit back and think and reflect
and not everybody understands that I
mean people might sort of thing that
you're not working but that's actually
not true this is completely necessary
ingredients to doing this and that is
why if you think about MSR we don't tell
our researchers what to work on but we
we hire the kind of individuals who are
very so self driven that they won't just
not do anything you know I mean so yeah
I think that there is a it's a balance
and an ebb and flow probably a little
bit yeah off the topic that but it's
like slow food and fast food sometimes
you have better benefits if you take
time to reduce the sauce and yeah but
the hamburger stays very good dog when
you're super hungry absolutely so Viktor
collaboration is a big deal in systems
and networking which totally makes sense
if you think about it networking what
individuals organizations industries do
you collaborate with and why do you
think it's so important to work together
on the kinds of problems you're
addressing yeah I actually believe in
this very deeply so there's multiple
types of collaboration of course some of
theirs the most obvious one is where
you're collaborating with engineers and
where you know you can sort of think
about they have some very hard problems
to work on and you know they're not sure
exactly how to go about it and so you
understand what they're trying to do and
then once you've understood that you try
to help and you're sort of collaborating
with them and so this is sort of the
typical research engineering
collaboration but if I step back I think
in research we have to collaborate with
more than just the product group guys
collaborating with leave it or not the
government is really important
government officials don't necessarily
know what is doable what is not doable
so you have to sort of work with them
for them to understand the aspects of
technology that can compromise people
and ones that don't we collaborate with
academia I mean this is the source of
talent that we are to hire and they have
to train these people to work with us so
then you know these brilliant people
that we work with once they understand
the problems we are working when and
students come and work with us as
interns that's another form of
collaboration and then a fourth form I
would say is just the businesses I mean
a lot of the stuff and technology is
actually creating new business models
right I mean if you think about Google I
mean one of the big success was not
necessarily the search they had a
breakthrough in the business model so
yeah I mean if you really want to be
successful you've got to work with all
these different individuals I think
which would players let's talk briefly
about network systems writ large what
are the historic challenges of network
systems and how is the landscape changed
with the advent of the cloud so I've
been doing this for a long time so I
guess I should be able to say the world
that I walked into after getting my
graduate degree to the world that exists
today is different but it's way more
exciting now than it was then
so when I graduated there was no cloud
okay there was this there was there was
the internet and even the internet had
not really picked up there was no web
for that matter the web happened after I
started working and I was working in
Wireless the telco industry was taking
off cellular networks who were big and
we were starting to connect to one
another our generation connected the
world and the next generation we'll
figure out what so in terms of
connecting the world we've gone into
many dimensions here but you asked
specifically by the cloud in the cloud
it's all about scale I mean we have such
massive scales today you know we have
something of the order of 54 regions and
these regions have multiple data centers
we've got who were 150 data centers
around the world and they are getting
further built we have tens of thousands
of miles of fiber in the wide area we
have hundreds of thousands of miles of
optics inside the data center so now
think about these millions of components
that are connected to one another and
you rely on them so much you don't want
them to fail ever no that's the problem
right we have now created these complex
systems and we rely so heavily on them
and we have to constantly figure out
what is the disap
with which we design we build we add
more features so we can do well so I
think that world earlier was a little
bit simpler but it was beautiful because
we were discovering new things now it
feels that we have discovered a bunch of
things but now everybody wants them and
so now it gets very very complicated to
try to make sure that everybody gets it
I love how you describe my generation
connected the world now you guys go
figure out how keep that going it's very
true in this it's very science every
generation this is our generations gift
to the next generation
it is Victor you have some great stories
from your career here there's one I'd
really like you to tell our audience
today and it's talking about how the
first wireless hotspot came about right
right
how many years ago was that that is a
1999 so I had graduated I'd gone got my
PhD while I was working and then I came
to Microsoft Research
I was this newly minted PhD and I wanted
to do something great with my life and
so we were in this building and I said
we will create a Wi-Fi network at that
time there was no Wi-Fi by the way there
was a standard this was called 802 at 11
and I wanted to create a lab out of this
building that I wasn't so one of my
managers was very supportive of that and
so he gave me the great night to do it
so I created that lab and I put it at 11
in that building so now this was also
the time when 3G networks were starting
to come and in the media everywhere you
read it did all talked about 3G they
talked about that's what was going to
create ubiquitous coverage
Bill Gates was a the CEO at that time
and we showed him what we had and we
convinced him and he made the decision
to expand this network that I've created
to all the buildings in Microsoft it was
about 35 buildings at the time and I was
a big deal there's nobody in the world
at that time who had this right so it
was build forward-looking vision that he
made that decision and made that happen
but then that lighted up everybody's
eyes and then other companies started to
look at oh maybe we should do it so as I
was thinking about all this stuff I
thought hey I got this going here like
probably do it in public spaces - I can
go to malls and I can go to shopping
centers and I can go to airports and I
can be connected I don't need the 3G
network I mean this is all indoor
technology all I need is a way to
authenticate people and whoever's put
the network there they can figure out
how they want to charge either they can
give it free or not so I wanted to do
this for real so I went to Crossroads
and said your shopping center would be
the first Wi-Fi hotspot in the world
they had this bragging rights that they
were convinced off so then over period
of a year and a half with a little
student of mine at the time he and I we
build us up and this actually ended up
becoming the first Wi-Fi hotspot
well before we get into two big topics
that I want to cover with you let's talk
for a minute about the breadth of work
that's coming out of your group and
there's a really exciting stuff going on
fantastic projects for example in live
video analytics so give us some
highlights of the research that we're
seeing in this area yeah just kind of
high-level and what research from other
groups has really enabled those products
to come to life yeah
so I like this project for a number of
reasons you know you asked me when we
began why I like this job or why I think
it's one of the best jobs so this is a
great example of deck that can be good
for business and it's good for society
right so the scenario is straightforward
you and a lot of people get all of us
get stuck in traffic and we want to not
be stuck in traffic that is just wasted
time so we started looking at the
cameras right and then we thought well
we've got all these cameras that are
taking this video of traffic flowing and
things with that made sure but they're
not doing anything active with it they
sort of like take the video and then
later on you and analyze it so that
guard is going in that space now there
are many technical problems here but I
think at the essence you asked me to
stay high level you should think of it
this way in Beijing there are 20 million
cameras and in London there was a camera
for every seven or eight people they are
in the cities if you go to New York you
see cameras and the question that you
ask is okay who's looking at the video I
mean when something bad happens you go
back and look at the video right and so
in this day and age why can't have
better technology where I can do vision
research there's been a lot of great
work that has gone on in vision to get a
vision and so we decided that we could
take some of that work we could build
these systems and roll them out to try
to take advantage of these streams and
create workflows that would happen
impact I would love to spend an entire
hour with you just on live video
analytics but we got to move on right
because I can't let an interview go by
with you without talking about the
dynamic spectrum disparity TV white
space you were there pretty well from
the beginning I was yes
so in broad strokes again tell us how
the TV white fight came about sure and
how its developed over the past couple
years yeah so you're right I was there
from the very beginning actually the my
stories on that starts the year 2003
when Craig Monday who is the CTO of this
organization took me out for dinner I
was again a young researcher and I
didn't know what it was about and he
started talking to me about this cable
DSL duopoly so he started to explain to
me how in rural America people had no
access internet right and the duopoly
concept was about the fact that
everybody was relying on these cable and
telcos to provide them connectivity and
they would provide connectivity where
their business model made sense so as he
was explaining this to me he started to
say well Richard we must be able to do
something in violence to prevent that
and then he said so are you gonna do
this think this exactly how are you
gonna do this and so here's a CTO of
microsoft search you know that time
asking me so that got me going on this
stuff and then this amazing thing
happened that we discovered that this
new spectrum was going to become
available and this was spectrum that was
reserved for digital TV it was being
used for analog TV and it was going to
be converted to digital TV and the rule
of thumb there is that digital TV will
use 1/3 the spectrum of the analog TV so
that means you've got 2/3 spectrum left
over right this is the frequencies that
are left over of course the telco
companies came and said we want that we
pay you for that and then you know we
went and said to them if you give it to
the telcos you'll have the same problem
here there are all these millions of
people in the US and even not you as
just billions around the world which we
will again be left or you would not have
solved the problems so what they did is
even though everybody was broadcasting
digital they started putting TV stations
in analog space do not to lose that
spectrum because they know they couldn't
say we sell it but they didn't want to
give it up - they knew this was a major
resource so this little serious problem
now for us so the technical problem then
became can you now sense the frequencies
if nobody is using it just using so that
is where we
this notion of opportunistic networking
and we went after that a lot of papers
and I'm not of like press now nobody was
really doing the work but we took on the
work we actually build a system like
that this was cutting edge nobody had
ever build anything like that
we brought the FCC Chairman I gave him a
two-and-a-half-hour a sort of a lecture
on how these things work I showed him
the network and Redmond campus and
showed him the demo he and his colleague
asked us all kinds of questions but we
send them convinced five days later they
warded to say yes let's unlicensed
spectrum is allowed nice and then so
this was a big big win for us and the
final thing I'd say is that Microsoft
now has an air band initiative where we
have promised to connect two million
people in the United States by 2020
based on this technology and in Africa
we've done the same thing hundreds of
thousands of students have come online
and they've written I've gotten mail
from them saying that this has change
their life they actually said God should
bless us because how much we had changed
their life Wow so yeah this is this is a
big story for me well and also if
listeners want to drill in a little bit
more I did a podcast with Ranbir Chandra
yeah who explained in more detail yeah
the dynamic spectrum TV white spaces all
right a lot of talk lately about edge
computing or the intelligent edge can
you give us an overview of what it is
and why it's important and what are the
big research challenges for edge
computing today glad when does cell use
storage and they sell you compute I want
them to sell your latency as well so
that's how we conceived of edge
computing it was actually conceived in
2009 so the idea of edge is that you
have many applications which are a
latency sensitive so edge is very very
important when computing has to be very
close to the data but then the devices
are not you don't want the devices to be
very big they're just very small so when
I thought about edge and conceived it
I thought about edge in conjunction with
cloud and what has happened in the last
two years is the marriage of the edge
with IOT any sector you look at it it's
all about ID is all about
Meishan and so it's all about sensors
and so now they have to connect to some
computing device and that's your edge
that's intelligent match so I think it
research there are many problems that
still need to be solved like all the
problems we solved in the cloud actually
applied to the edge to things like
availability reliability security all
that has to be solved and now this
domain and the assumptions that were
made for the cloud are a little bit
different from the edge so where does
that live in the research organization
what kinds of things are you working on
to make that yeah so the biggest things
about reliability so you know if you're
going to create a dependency of your
business on the cloud you need to make
sure that the edge is always available
so I think one other problem is that in
the cloud you've got hundreds of
thousands of machines and we know how to
make availability if something goes down
we use a switch you or you won't even
know now an edge we don't control the
system because it's sitting on your
premise it's some heterogeneous piece of
hardware so we've been thinking about
how do we give you the same sense of
security that you have in terms of the
availability of the system as we haven't
laughs so that's one problem you would
not other problems have to do with
security I've been sort of is working
with talk to some researchers yesterday
about there's this problem with physical
security in cloud we have everything
contained it's lock and key people are
watching you know you put the edge here
now you can have physical security
problems where people can actually turn
some things off take the disc out I read
it put it back in how would you ever
know if this happened and one of the
things that always came up was that
we're building these data centers so
quickly why do we need these edges so
one other thing was to just build
applications that convinces people that
you can do this without flour so we've
been doing that as well you know I
talked to Ben Zorn a while ago and we
talked about the amount of things and
how not unregulated necessarily that I
could make a device and can you know
sell it to you yeah and I don't have all
of the same fallbacks that I put into it
so you've got a smart doorbell you have
a smart fork connected to everything and
it's like a host of problems yes it's
very serious if you think of it so we
all like this stuff but when things go
down you know what are you gonna do
right please aha
so who goes first anyway but seriously
though so I think the challenge for all
of us is to actually build
self-sustaining system self managing
systems and but I don't say that too
much because when I say that they always
tends to take people in the direction of
oh my god we are going to the matrix so
we're going to something yeah see
there's a whole question I asked all of
the researchers what keeps you up at
night but yeah we've kind of covered
that sure okay so let's talk about a big
thing and kind of live there for a
second the big announcement this week of
the open network emulator yes which
seems to be predicated on the underlying
assumption that the cloud is too big to
fail to you the phrase tell us about
open network emulator when is it why do
we need it how did you build it yeah the
open network emulator is once again now
it's gonna become a theme in this
podcast about reliability and
availability yeah let me put it in
perspective as to what it is as the name
suggests it's an emulator it emulates
networks and we've known that for a long
time how to do that but it's been very
hard to emulate cloud skill networks
right these are very very large as have
been saying again and again the larger
story here is verification the network
verification and the way network
verification ties into availability is
as follows so let's say everything is
working perfectly well barring hardware
failure everything should be fine
but then somebody who is part of your
team goes and changes something
somewhere and I have horror stories
about that that I can tell you but I
will not but go isn't changes something
at some point and that thing as has to
happen the bass can bring down an entire
region because you know if you break the
network your packets are going nowhere
and now going to the right places let's
fill it that way and that's a complete
nono for businesses right so this thing
talking about what keeps me up at night
if something happens somewhere things
will go bad millions of people will get
back impacted and I don't want to be the
source of that right so the emulator was
built to prevent that and the way the
emulator works is that now network
engineers and operators when they do
changes they make the change but they
actually don't even know if they're
making the change
the network they actually are changing
the emulator because it mimics the the
network underneath so amazingly that you
can't tell the difference so once you
make the changes the emulator will then
try them out and make sure everything is
good
once everything is good it's gonna go
and put in that network below and voila
if we did it work right